The reality-warping nature of Crisis on Infinite
Earths brings up loads of questions about
not only the Arrowverse, but the worlds beyond
the CW's series.
Some of these questions may be answered in
the coming months, and some may never be answered
at all.
The first three parts of Crisis bring some
incredible cameos, but the one that lit the
internet on fire was saved for Part 4 Ezra
Miller, who appears as the Flash in 2017's
Justice League, comes face-to-face with Grant
Gustin's CW version of the character as the
latter is traveling through the Speed Force.
Neither of them have any idea of how the meeting
is possible, and the movie Flash in particular
seems completely oblivious, though the pair
get a somewhat awkward moment appreciating
each others' costumes.
As the TV Flash says, this shouldn't be able
to happen.
At this point the multiverse has been annihilated
by the anti-matter wave.
So if the DCEU films are meant to take place
in the same multiverse as the Arrowverse,
the movie Flash should be wiped out along
with the rest of that Earth's heroes.
"You've been gone for months.”
“What are you talking about ....I just left
two seconds ago."
One possible explanation is that time in the
Speed Force doesn't work the same as it does
on Earth.
We've already seen this is the case in previous
seasons of The Flash.
So, as confusing as it may seem, it could
be the movie Flash entered the Speed Force
before the multiverse's death and the Force's
strange relationship with time is allowing
him to meet the TV Flash after the end of
all things.
One of the coolest things about Crisis on
Infinite Earths is the reprisal of Brandon
Routh in the role of Superman.
In earlier chapters of Crisis he plays the
Superman of Earth-96, who is largely based
on the 1996 miniseries Kingdom Come.
Routh's Earth-96 Superman has earned some
gray hairs and his costume insignia incorporates
the color black something uncommon for the
character outside of Kingdom Come.
He's killed by Lex Luthor at the end of Crisis
Part 3, but by the end of the event we learn
the restoration of the multiverse has resurrected
the hero.
During the resolution of Crisis Part 5, we
see snapshots of other corners of the multiverse,
including Earth-96.
We find a smiling Superman flying in orbit
over the Earth.
Interestingly, his costume has changed.
The black of his trademark insignia has been
replaced with yellow, and overall his costume
looks much more like the one Routh wore in
2006's Superman Returns.
We don't know if the change is a conscious
choice on Superman's part or a result of the
changes in the multiverse.
One possibility is that it's meant to signify
the character has found some peace.
When he's asked about the black in the costume
earlier in Crisis, he says it symbolizes that
there's hope even in the darkest of times.
Perhaps this version of the Man of Steel no
longer finds himself in the darkest of times,
and decided to let it show.
Oliver Queen dies a second time at the end
of Crisis Part 4, and this one might just
stick.
With the powers of the Spectre, Queen dies
battling the Anti-Monitor and helping to restore
the multiverse.
His sacrifice is lamented by all the heroes
in Part 5, and the President of the United
States calls for a moment of silence in honor
of his deeds.
Even if we accept this is, finally, the end
of a character who has already died and come
back multiple times in the history of the
Arrowverse, we're left with the question of
what happened to Spectre.
We don't know a lot about the Arrowverse's
version of the Spectre.
He's introduced in Crisis Part 3 when James
Corrigan approaches Oliver Queen in Purgatory
about acting as the spirit's new host, and
by Part 4 Oliver has assumed his new role.
In the comics, the Spectre is the physical
embodiment of the wrath of God and one of
the most powerful superheroes of DC.
If the Spectre of the CW is similar to that
of the comics, the death of Oliver Queen would
likely not mean the death of the Spectre,
but instead the spirit would need a new host.
So, did the Spectre find one?
Did it go back to James Corrigan?
Or is it possible Oliver isn't dead, and will
continue to act as the Spectre in the shadows?
Crisis Part 3 introduces us to Ryan Choi,
the Paragon of Humanity.
He's one of the only Paragons to be introduced
in Crisis, at least as far as the Arrowverse
is concerned.
But DC Comics readers are more familiar with
the name.
Choi famously replaces Ray Palmer as the shrinking
hero Atom in the All-New Atom comic series.
While Choi's solo series didn't last, he remained
a hero in the DC universe, most recently being
recruited into an eccentric Justice League
of America lineup that included the reformed
villain Killer Frost and the alien bounty
hunter Lobo.
His appearance naturally had fans wondering
if he'd be joining the super-powered club
by the end of Crisis, but Part 5 concludes
without Choi obtaining any shrinking powers
or a suit of armor similar to Ray Palmer's.
"This definitely makes me question again why
I'm here."
But that doesn't mean Choi couldn't play a
larger role in the Arrowverse's future, and
possibly as another version of the Atom.
As soon as we meet him in Crisis, he makes
it clear he's familiar with Ray Palmer's scientific
breakthroughs, and it's Choi who comes up
with the idea of making a device that will
neutralize the Anti-Monitor by making him
shrink infinitely.
Whether or not this is a sign of things to
come, only time will tell.
Crisis Part 5 ends with the multiverse restored,
but not exactly as it used to be.
The various heroes of the different CW Arrowverse
series existed on a few separate Earths before
Crisis, but they now share the same world
Earth Prime.
"It's normal to see us together?"
"Well, normally you'd also have Green Arrow
and a Legend or two."
But what about the rest of the multiverse?
We don't revisit Earth-89, where we saw Robert
Wuhl reprise the role of intrepid Batman-hunting
reporter Alexander Knox.
We don't get another visit with the Robin
of Earth-66.
And we don't see the fate of Earth-167, where
the events of Smallville take place.
It's likely we won't see most of those worlds
again in the Arrowverse series, and really,
that's okay.
What could have an impact on the Arrowverse
going forward are some of the alternate Earths
we visited before Crisis.
For example, there's Earth-X, where the CW
heroes put a dent in the Nazi ruling faction
in the 2017 crossover Crisis on Earth-X - and
made it easier for The Ray to go back home
and take them out for good.
Or what about Earth-90, which was destroyed
as part of the 2018 crossover Elseworlds?
Was the Barry Allen of the '90s Flash show
resurrected as part of the multiverse's restoration?
In Crisis Part 3, Constantine, Diggle, and
Mia travel to Earth-666 as part of their quest
to resurrect Oliver Queen.
There, we meet Tom Ellis' Lucifer Morningstar
from the series Lucifer.
From their back and forth it's clear Lucifer
and Constantine have had dealings before,
and in particular Lucifer says something which
has had fans of the Arrowverse and Lucifer
scratching their heads.
"Okay, I'm only doing this because I owe you
for Maze."
Maze, or Mazikeen, is a regular character
on Lucifer played by Lesley-Ann Brandt.
She's a demon who used to be the most feared
torturer in all of Hell.
But by the end of Part 5 we get no indication
of exactly what Constantine did for Maze and
Lucifer.
Not even Lucifer showrunners Joe Henderson
and Ildy Modrovich know what the former monarch
of Hell was talking about.
They told EW the line was as much a surprise
to them as it was to the fans.
If the issue is ever to be addressed on Lucifer,
it will have to be in its upcoming fifth and
final season.
Otherwise, Lucifer and/or Maze will have to
make one more visit to the Arrowverse, or
fans will be left to wonder.
Early in Part 5 of Crisis, we learn one of
the biggest changes in the restored multiverse
is that only Supergirl and the other Paragons
remember Lex Luthor as being the villain we
all know he is.
When Supergirl first awakens in the new Earth
Prime, she's late to cover Lex being awarded
the Nobel Peace Prize, and we soon learn he's
somehow the head of the D.E.O.
Even close allies of Supergirl, like her sister
Alex, look up to Lex as some kind of benevolent
philanthropist.
"He's the best guy."
No, he's not; he's a psychopathic lunatic!"
"What?"
The most likely answer to how this came to
be is that it was by Lex's design.
Just before Oliver Queen's confrontation with
the Anti-Monitor and the formation of the
new multiverse, Lex reminds the other Paragons
he still has a piece of the Book of Destiny
which he'd previously used to kill the Superman
of Earth-96 and take his place.
With the remaining pieces of the Book of Destiny,
coupled with his own intellect, Lex may have
figured a way to consciously will himself
into a new role on Earth Prime.
“So this is what being a hero feels like..
interesting...?”
Regardless of how he did it, Jon Cryer's been
a hit in his portrayal of one of DC's chief
villains, and it's good to know Crisis is
unlikely to be the end of his time as Lex
Luthor.
Toward the end of Part 5, Lois Lane drops
a bombshell and Tyler Hoechlin's Superman
seems just as surprised as the rest of us.
Lois calls Superman as he's flying through
the clouds and tells him he needs to get to
Metropolis, saying simply, "It's the boys."
Superman dives toward the Earth, presumably
on his way home, but we never get to see these
boys for ourselves.
The last time we left them, Superman and Lois
had one child, Jonathan.
The newborn lends some much needed humor to
exposition scenes with The Monitor, as he
keeps interrupting the alien's portents of
doom with his crying.
But somehow the restoration of the multiverse
has given Lois and Clark at least one more
son.
This is a departure not only from the pre-Crisis
CW, but from the comics.
Jonathan is the son of Lois and Clark in the
comics though he's the teenage Superboy and
a member of the Legion of Super-Heroes.
"You know when I used to picture us together,
we were living on Earth, and we had two kids."
It's an interesting twist that's sure to cause
the pair complications down the road.
We'll likely learn who these sons are, how
many there are, and whether they've inherited
any of their father's abilities either in
future episodes of Supergirl, or in their
own upcoming series Superman & Lois.
In Crisis Part 2, the heroes encounter the
earlier version of a cowboy anti-hero they've
had dealings with in the past Jonah Hex, played
by Johnathon Schaech.
They're confronted by Hex in a mine on Earth-18
where they're looking for a Lazarus Pit to
resurrect Oliver Queen.
Sara Lance and Mia fight and overpower Hex,
who as of yet doesn't have his trademark scar.
When Jonah, restrained by Sara, refuses to
yield and give them permission to be in the
mine, Sara says "Guess you were going to get
this scar eventually," and cuts into his face
with a knife.
In the comics, Hex's scar comes from a fire
and it doesn't look like an injury that a
knife would cause all on its own.
If this is actually meant to be the event
that marks Jonah Hex for good, the fact that
the multiverse essentially gets a big reboot
might undo it.
Hex doesn't appear at all after Part 2 of
the event, so as of yet we have no idea whether
or not he still has Sara to thank for his
good looks.
In Crisis Part 2, Batwoman and Supergirl travel
to Earth-99 where they believe they can find
the Paragon of Courage that world's version
of Batman.
Instead, they find an old, broken Bruce Wayne
who is content to let his world and the rest
of the multiverse die.
We learn at some point this version of Batman
crossed the line and killed one of his enemies,
after which killing eventually became his
default.
He even killed his world's version of Superman.
"Battle not with monsters, lest you become
a monster."
But we never learn what it was that pushed
Batman over the edge.
We get a few dark details, but they all seem
to have happened after he went rogue.
He mentions the Batwoman of Earth-99 died,
but this looks likely to have happened after
Batman went bad, because Bruce says his Kate
first became Batwoman because she "thought
she could succeed where I failed" implying
he'd already been corrupted before she even
became a hero.
His final battle with Superman would be an
unlikely source, considering he would have
already gone down a much darker road in order
to become Superman's target.
If we absolutely had to guess, then it seems
a good bet it was the Joker who finally drove
the Dark Knight to cross the uncrossable line.
We know the clown has brought other versions
of Batman close to the brink before.
Still, the Bruce Wayne of Earth-99 dies without
ever mentioning specifics, so we'll probably
never know for sure.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies and TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.